j'ai une commande pour pascal leroy a
m'a donné ont valu filet puisque c'est
ça une soupe
le matériel qui sait qu'ils bossent ici
c'est l'abbé pierre ou quoi tiens machin
tu repenses à être ton gros cartable il
a plus faim t'inquiète us ou pourquoi
pas un potage
[Rires]
[Musique]
quand tu te retrouves à bosser l'accueil
toi on lui fait payer des choses avec de
l'argent donc alors que tu vois c'est
une vraie vocation
alors je bossais à la queue dans un parc
d'attractions je me suis barré
j'avais un collègue qui était beaucoup
moins cool que toi et plein de qualités
mais il avait le défaut relouer genre
coin trop bavard pédophiles
ah oui ça c'est un vrai défaut ça
surtout dans la parc d'attraction avec
les gars ça fout mal au mal non plus
corps de métier après attention hein le
parc était pas au point où l'on en
galets et intelligent pour permettre
dans cette de motivation dans la case
plus gros défaut il avait mis
perfectionniste un peu pédophiles voilà
non seulement vous avez su qu'il était
un pédophile ont passé à 11 des experts
dans son costume et bat pas si
perfectionniste que ça le pédophile à
l'eau wen ont livré pas passée je sais
pas il s'est peut-être dit qu'il avait
pas risquer sa vie juste pour un velouté
sellerie pascal à pascal ce mec là il
partage sa voix avec les bus d'accord tu
te rends pas compte du courage qu'il a
il aurait pu mourir sans foi l'a écrasée
par un camion comme le hacker la dent
ennemi d'état n'a pas la réf
puis entre nous parce qu'allah la
prochaine fois commande un truc qui vaut
le prix de la vie d'un livreur je sais
par genre des nuggets ou des quesadillas
et si t'es pas content parce qu'aller
battu les tombereaux cuma le moule et
dont on porte un court trop large tu vas
en salle de pause à un distributeur
rempli de 16 litres liebig tomates ok
personne n'en bois sauf toi alors m'a
dit fais toi plaisir et entre nous parce
qu'à la tap a besoin de sous c'est
pourquoi parce que t'es trop grand tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire que t'es
trop grand et dans ton corps il ya deux
personnes qui te pilotes comme dans
pacific rim
il a pas la rave [ __ ] mais tu vas
jamais aussi et bien tant mieux si on
tue kasr el habib sy dr il a tué et fait
tuer tuer tuer tuer tuer tuer tuer tuer
et toi ton entretien d'embauché
j'habite loin dans la case mon plus gros
défaut timide voilà appareils